heyyyyyy to sense viewers here with a
special announcement make sure you make
it to the end of the video where we get
to share some exciting news you're
pregnant again the United States has the
world's largest economy and our workers
have some of the highest salaries in the
world but if you think that most
Americans have piles of money create
credit and low amounts of debt you'd be
wrong
since you're following our channel it's
probably obvious to you that our
financial literacy is at crisis levels
but have you ever stopped to wonder what
led us to this point and more
importantly what can be done to change
it in 2015 the espied global financial
literacy survey asked for simple
financial questions to respondents all
over the world and the results landed
the u.s. in 14th place for financial
know-how and it shows Americans are
failing the grade by nearly every metric
nearly 60 percent of US households don't
keep a budget two-thirds would be unable
to scrounge up a thousand dollars for an
emergency and thirty five percent have a
debt currently in collections the
average college student carries $30,000
in student loans and floats a credit
card balance of around $8,000 the median
retirement savings for Americans aged 55
to 64 is around $100,000 an amount that
would translate to just three hundred
and ten dollars a month of income in
retirement and it's especially scary for
our generation even though 69 percent of
Millennials rape their own financial
knowledge highly only 24 percent are
able to demonstrate basic financial
literacy one of the biggest factors is
the lack of any formal financial lessons
in schools even though the Council for
economic education found that piece
see you financial education are more
likely to save more likely to pay off
their credit cards each month and less
likely to become compulsive buyers only
at earnest states currently offer it and
of those that do most of them
incorporate the subject inside of
another course of study like economics
math or social studies only five states
require a semester long course focused
on personal finance but the problems
don't stop there the minute high
schoolers graduate they've gotten a
target on their backs and the financial
industry is lying in wait credit card
companies are notorious for luring kids
into high interest credit cards with
offers of t-shirts or a free pizza
despite the fact that most students have
little to no income and hardly any
real-world financial experience
unfortunately the trend to financial
institutions targeting the non savvy
doesn't let up as you get older current
rules in the u.s. allow brokers under
the guise of financial advisors to put
their own financial interests ahead of
consumers when selling a financial
product or reel to be fair the financial
industry does engage in some education
but consider this in 2013
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
reported that while 670 million dollars
was spent by the industry on consumer
education 17 billion dollars was spent
on marketing their products that's a
ratio of 25 to 1 chump change make no
mistake the cumulative results of people
not saving enough of getting into
financial trouble doesn't just fall on
them and their families but on society
as a whole so what can we do to help
promote change consistently scoring at
the top of such surveys are the
Scandinavian countries like Denmark
Norway and Sweden there are a lot of
reasons for this in Sweden's case for
instance there is a long cultural
tradition of saving no major disasters
in the financial markets to undermine
trust in the system and the presence of
the Financial Supervisory Authority a
strong government agency designed to
regulate the entire financial services
industry but probably most important is
that the kids are taught about the
basics of personal finance starting in
the first grade and continuing all the
way up to high
school changes have to be made to
education here in America if we're gonna
stand a chance of improving things and
you don't have to be a parent to
advocate for a child's right to quality
financial education you can look at this
map to see what standards for financial
literacy your state currently mayonnaise
you can also reach out to your state
representative to let them know what
you'd like to see offered to future
generations
unfortunately the primary reasons cited
for not including this kind of education
in schools is that it's the parents job
but we all know that's not really
happening nearly half of Americans don't
talk with their children about money at
all and it's not because they don't
think they should it's because most
simply don't know what to say if you're
a parent or hope to be one someday you
do not have to be an expert to teach
kids about money simply getting them
their own bank account seems to have
positive results with 15 year olds
scoring 40 points higher in financial
literacy than those without one kids
also learn best by doing so next time
you sit down to pay your bills online
call your kid over and coach them
through how to do it themselves for
bonus points check out our previous
video about how to talk to kids about
money this is so important because if
finances aren't talked about much
growing up we tend to continue that
approach of avoidance even when we leave
home we just stumble along assuming
everyone knows more than we do
afraid to call attention to our
ignorance and it's that unspoken taboo
around the topic of money that allows
this negative feedback loop to continue
thankfully it's never been easier to
take your financial education into your
own hands the last decade has seen a
tsunami of blogs podcasts programs books
and courses aimed at filling in the
adult education gap when it comes to
finance and there are tons of amazing
free or low-cost resources out there
hundreds of libraries all over the
country host MoneySmart weeks where they
cover topics like retirement budgeting
and credit without any incentive to make
you a paying customer there's also the
National Endowment of financial
education website is smart about money
org with lots of free courses you can
even ask
employer to bring in a financial
educator after all a better educated
workforce is in everyone's interest as a
dedicated watcher of two cents we hope
you continue to broaden your own
financial education and don't keep the
lessons you're learning all to yourself
we expect you to share your newly earned
money smarts with those you care about
changing the face of financial literacy
here in the states and around the world
is not just our job it's yours too and
that's our two cents the vast majority
of financial education out there is
funded by big corporations we and our
co-creators chose to partner with PBS
specifically because we believe
financial education should be free from
for-profit hidden agendas and over the
last year it's been made abundantly
clear you guys want that too we've
gained hundreds of thousands of
subscribers scooped up a bunch of awards
and are blessed with a community of
enthusiastic people willing to share
their stories and experiences but did
you know that each episode takes between
40 and 50 hours of work to make yeah
these amazing visuals and carefully
written scripts are being made by a team
of full-time professionals so I think
you can tell where we're going here
we're starting a patreon now before you
groan we of all people know how
important your hard-earned dollars are
and we have given our perks a lot of
thought to make it worth your while
that's right we're going to be inviting
you backstage for an intimate look
behind the scenes a new space to chat
together as a community and even the
chance to digitally hang out with us on
a monthly basis also as a special
limited time offer will be providing
everyone who contributes in the next two
weeks a special budget template
personally designed by us to help you
create your ideal budget from top
we hope that this show has provided you
value and you'll consider joining us in
our mission to change the world's
relationship to their money through
education it's a big vision and we can't
do it without you
[Music]
where did you learn about money from
your school your parents YouTube let us
know in the comments
[Music]